okay [ __ ] we're back in this
bare-chested gamer is he's ready to go
yeah he has no sure but he's fine daddy
oh i see well [ __ ] brothers up to I'm
talking horn hey [ __ ] hey mom okay yeah
sure honey ok your live show honey you
feel like talking about school yet not
really any idea who might want to do
that because honey I am out is I really
am dying to find out why he decided up
to up in a band all the plans we made as
a family she's not Maris is coming from
my cell you know you're the foot first
barosky to go Khalid get my mind out I
only heard that since I was like 60
honey we planted foot since you were
born it's been a good 18 years guys all
kinds trouble just for you to decide it
wasn't what you should be are you like
I'm one you lose again like I'm the
moody one in his house you are the moody
one of this house well enjoy this house
while we still have it [ __ ] what what's
happening to the house maybe it just
isn't where we should be now this is a
funny don't worry about it don't worry
about anything why start now go off and
do whatever it is you do you know what
neighbors had more examples of you now
getting out and make them something to
myself no no I want to get to maybe
wanted me to get out of here because you
never got around to doing yourself maybe
I'm just the most recent failure a lot
of failures that is our family yeah
that's [ __ ] up didn't you just quarter
i sold one I'm living now you're a
taurus all part totally spread those ass
cheeks party let that [ __ ] you looked
at what you thing out you essentially
stopped me just would not stop you
completely I'm looking I'm looking
please comes wrong anyway see what my
body's up to you know [ __ ] what
my body is up to and I'm actually hang
was because she's kind of emails like
the past and cannot stay long hangouts
Greg this [ __ ] down here ya makka I'll
cops don't care come tonight to get me
that cup for what are you doing blocking
off the road oh yeah what I want to do
that without a gun now if we type of
shot someone no selfish one you kill
them are you saying it over the news
that you should carry a battle-axe that
will be impressive I'll look into it
opossums bags however everything is so
great in harvesting which plays just
left to get halloween whatever I just
wanna head out and get ready to put
tonight do that Parkin laundering been
kicking power see ya well i get home i
do i'm still home and get ready for the
hollers bed yeah yep
let make a change [ __ ] I wear
the shirt and when peoples are like I I
the nipples are hard and ice baby but
nettles are hot the Harley the Felix
wanna lose it out is it out of my
nipples the nipples are move on and
petroleum oil up what the [ __ ] are you
what the [ __ ] help i'm stuck in a time
warp how sara kennedy school of this
video game I'm a good person I fetch ya
know my clothes oh yes soundgin spoke a
yes sweet mother [ __ ] which Doug let's
do this [ __ ] but do this time to
get my panties with half assed [ __ ]
and it was all ok yeah where's my buddy
Greg
just music though hey where's the cigs
let's start tim is an evening there's a
[ __ ] name it whatever agree that a
chamber commerce as we big for this geez
i hear ya what ok so usually you won't
have any lines what I had like three
no-shows what it's helping a stupid in
and one cares about big plays with the
fog barn okay yeah I would probably save
your ass I might have this memorized and
when I was kid probably not the ruler
like sick time last two years would be
spooky so it's like twenty percent
actual history and like it so good guess
where it starts up narrow but yet anyway
you got like five as per your lives and
do is [ __ ] and see their be guess
you're able to give health a possum
springs came to be through the mists of
time I say where is for travelers from
1793 brother John yes brother seven from
this vantage point I do spy a deep
hollow and within a great dead tree and
besides with a witch bring the starway
brother Stephen we're truly my store is
parched from these long and are just
travels and carrying three hundred
beaver pelts let us make haste Oh
excellent brother yet Oh travelers help
an extra mile woman plays house but I
must have said to just stroll by
youthful form for once I was a couple of
that
Haggard which how about to like a pan
curl young man he did not even offered
one of the three hundred fine beaver
pelt to what my ancient [ __ ] I shall
curse yeah ma and this very night ye
shall perish I'm fearful study brother
Stephen I do not venture out into these
hills the joust words with a hell hang
yeah I was born among these trades made
the Harvest Moon and ye shall die under
that mound but the John I'm Brian
Facebook brother stephen i'd also easily
shaken by the railings of an old [ __ ]
come help me carry these three hundred
beaver pelts little did anyone know as a
width did not curse
oh sure how he'll have a parabola that's
Greg by the moon it says above us
adverse each day what is a trouble not
that Uranus yep I which yep that's where
the friend that this very day this
horrifying Crone did curse my brother
and I to die the ones we kept by this
very spring beneath the dead tree my la
vaca and even now his body lies upon the
earth mother [ __ ] life was all about
300 beam pelts oh it should be hot hey
the curse of town road young man that's
not cute skirts of spring and knowledge
shall die I'm also one done for I have
drinketh of the water don't leave me
here Greg buddy and yet even there the
curses lots of blood would not be saying
[Music]
gaze upon them gaze upon these spirits
whether we are now guests and i'm told
meant about the accusing layer of 300
ghostly papers it would seem that all
who died here are cursed never leave
that's a twitch know what she had done
and crap for for each me is trimmed of
his own path may be spat lead only to
his end ok any path early the place was
on now this is bench you from the bus
station young wench it is I they gather
the forest just to expect you to ain't
that the way so which thou has Todd too
long in this world I benefit a wonder in
my ass all through the stranger places I
guess I what got Hannity now and would
let me speak with them to you will begin
in my end and I say no what but that is
not the whole other story I this is your
life have you know so much about my
horoscope that has no power here for now
that I'm beginners act my infernal power
sure young which even now your [ __ ] is
getting with her and who can say what
lift in the world to come Wow there were
as you would go for that I guess we'll
take care as I love us cut our losses
and that was founded in this festival
Halloween we shall celebrate the dying
of the year in the founding opossum
Springs I'm a ghost a Korean the beaver
population suffered decline their bigs
experts are corn and pumpkins I used to
be the candidate now laid before I can
see well oh no audience and that's how
she'll be careful as your lady I bet you
that's my looked about Darkman pick up
wire up both support is pretty low
[Music]
appropriately bit differently given and
the pursuit acre the [ __ ] giveth and
the [ __ ] taken okay thanks guys I never
doing that again so what are we doing
now well I'm going home thank you make
me dinner we're going to watch our
movies can I come it's more a date out
but i eard aren't they Chamber of
Commerce folks are going to stay up a
dance out to kind of have to go business
stuff like that but you're good at it
person who sings every true can I come
nope okay well adios [ __ ] adios
betcha this is garbage it's this guy
[Music]
wow that was really into the best
evidence tonight
but that oh my god hey yeah
above
how do they go chef
[Music]
it's like a shake
[Music]
that's above my pay grade
okay the cops room I'm sorry they've not
ready
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] Asher help going down here
to lick my pass a the last thing I would
want to someone watching my house a look
at these like this guinea's on a
[ __ ]
Kenya's in a bay and that control is not
really
[Music]
pastore [ __ ] the long saw it
it's are gonna hang out a sign i guess i
start to band practice today [ __ ]
hate vampires that guy's figure so thank
you yeah my [ __ ] epiny are gonna lie
i'm not scared they just being difficult
even hey hon sing apologize I should
[ __ ] just leave company one hey hey
mom you like really tired seddie yeah so
it's splitting headache well the weather
things are weird with you great and
really kick up for that today the
apologize [ __ ] hey hun yeah sorry
yesterday yeah [ __ ] cut you [ __ ] I
don't really mean what I said though
yeah why they meant a not that isn't how
we should create a good i don't want us
to stop talking I just don't want to
repeat a few years ago the motor mouth
yeah okay I'm fine guess I'm just oh
just some voice stuff last night i think
i saw when i talk about it later step on
it together you talk about school also
later and I like to like strawberries
what a [ __ ] blows chuckles you guys
hang out Gregory
yes
slate tonight chicken run I'll run it
however the prince again we're here
back ask oh snap stop it snack pack em
back back in I could use some snacky
pills right about now
now dragons work hello I'm with an M
probably something dumb initiate phase
of life
hey gar gar a letter a uptown
subset hybrid night what's up let's say
your band back cool which outfit we're
going to head out the bank 950 is
[ __ ] hard Yokum risked are you slow
day I'm not going to talk on this blog
practice because last time I [ __ ]
messed up ok ich rufe door yeah door top
of the stairs that goes out into the
room yeah I can like I don't run from
that door down lobby up to the word
would be able to side of the balcony and
maybe not but what's the software in a
person doing the tail there they'll be
fine sorry I just not let's go let's do
this [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wattles [ __ ] hard that was [ __ ]
hard i hate of that i'm leaving the band
whoa so fast he just pushed a button i'm
so tired i shamed my buck accords Yellin
awesome I'm gonna sound so husky and
anyway I don't even know if the dream
Sanada and the sky where things would go
kidnap some kid and also I think it was
my head after while I was sleeping
anyway I need to go do something because
it was scary that's not what is
expecting you tonight are you okay dude
yeah not like losing her or something
probably wasn't a ghost yeah probably
not yeah that's only okay I'm fine I'll
go for good and done myself oh dude
don't be like that you gotta do okay man
so we need to maybe say if they're like
some ghost he's done hopped around here
like from a source we can trust such as
as you see if we have a ghost section
what why is that a dumb question you
know we could go check the library for
books about it now like they had local
paper on Fox on the back accenture
there's some secret history of the
kidnap go find that probably oh I didn't
know they have that I thought it was
just like a broken-down little bunch of
books its last time we actually have one
of the nicer ones around how put you to
pay for way back when yeah they said Oh
pecan deschanel there for my let's go
can we review up after a shark okay
we'll be back well hope go says that's
the spirit the library
look jobs weird like when this was
painted it was like hey I got the right
now well working things like right now
it's like one of the graph a tomorrow
after someone gets shot how to hit by a
car yeah it's really affecting you
forget we live in separate realities
Josh clearly better okay guys i'm here
today I gotta head out anyways hope you
enjoyed a 22-minute section thank